bom
[Aplausos]
então chama Murilo Duarte mas as pessoas
não me conhecem pelo meu nome mas sim
como favelado investidor o que muitas
pessoas não imaginam é que meu primeiro
investimento não foi em ações ou em
tesouro direto foi um livro tudo começou
em 2015 e quando era menor aprendiz um
cartório no centro de São Paulo e foi o
mesmo ano que eu comecei a Faculdade o
meu salário era de 680 reais EA
mensalidade já com desconto
640 sobravam apenas 40 reais por mês eu
vou contar agora para você o que me
levou a fazer esse primeiro investimento
que foi em conhecimento eu nasci na
favela do Jardim João 23 localizado aqui
na zona oeste de São Paulo a minha
infância sempre foi rodeada pela questão
da escassez financeira mas graças a Deus
nunca faltou um arroz um feijão dentro
de casa eu lembro que nós e como toda
criança eu queria ter uma chuteira uma
bola de futebol ou em um passeio na
escola mas infelizmente minha mãe não
tinha condições financeira de
proporcionar isso aí você falou nos
Episódios que mais me feriu na minha
infância mas sem dúvidas o que mais me
machucou foram as experiências negativas
dentro da escola na primeira série Eu
lembro que eu fui o último aluno até o
material escolar dentro da Serra eu
passei ali 30 dias pedindo folha para os
amigos ao lado para que eu pudesse
copiar o que era passado na Luso mas o
que de fato me machucou e que fica na
minha mente até hoje foi relacionado o
que eu passei na quinta série era uma
escola nova aqui também numa escola
pública e nessa escola era exigido que
eu tivesse uniforme escolar só que a
minha mãe não tinha condições ainda de
comprar e a minha professora de
português me cobrava todo santo dia
aquele uniforme até que um dia eu me
irritei e falei com chorando minha mãe
não tem condições de comprar um uniforme
eu venho o carro porque eu tenho ea é
bom que ela me chamou de pobretão na
frente da sala toda eu abaixei a cabeça
abrir meu caderno e na última folha eu
escrevi eu vou ser rir Nunca mais eu vou
passar nenhuma vergonha relacionado ao
Dinheiro Deus meus 16 anos eu arrumei
meu primeiro trabalho que foi como
auxiliar de padeiro E aí o meu salário
era de 500 reais metade desse salário eu
contribui a planeta de casa para ajuda
da minha mãe EA outra metade eu fiz meu
primeiro planejamento financeiro quero
comprar um computador porque todos meus
amigos já tinham computador exceto eu e
foi então que eu trabalhei 6 meses para
comprar esse computador e que finalmente
eu realizei esse primeiro planejamento
financeiro aos meus 19 anos eu lembro de
sempre está xingando o Jornal Nacional e
ver o William Bonner falando SELIC subiu
inflação caiu bolsa está subindo o Bolsa
tá despencando E até que eu me
questionei falei pois aqui nesse tão
importante porque ele fala sobre isso
aqui todo dia e eu nunca e bom e foi
isso que eu guardei na mente eu preciso
aprender sobre tesouro direto sobre
Equação toda essa parada e aí aos meus
20 anos quando eu fui trabalhar dentro
do cartório que os 40 reais que me
sobrou eu poderia ter ido no Mac poderia
ter juntado com um rolê no final de
semana só que eu escolhi investir em
conhecimento eu fui na livraria e
comprei o meu primeiro livro da vida que
foi sobre o tesouro direto mas na época
não tinha muito tempo para ler Porque eu
trabalhava e fazer a faculdade então
único tempo que de certa forma eu tinha
um pouco ansioso era dentro do ônibus
porque eu dormia para descansar então eu
saio que eu fiquei esse meu descanso e
pronto para desenvolver na questão de
mercado financeiro e aí eu mais curioso
porque o meu melhor amigo veio junto
comigo nesse projeto de aprender mais
sobre o mercado financeiro como tudo
então em determinados meses eu pegava o
meu livro emprestava para ele e
vice-versa então chamei isso que eu não
comprava alívio né então Se não
conseguir economizar E foi aí que eu
consegui juntar r$ 120 e fiz no meu
primeiro investimento financeiro e foi
no tesouro direto eu lembro que eu tava
dentro de ônibus lotado o celular na mão
já tinha transferido o dinheiro para
fazer um investimento e na hora de
apertar o botão deu aquele frio na
barriga né porque era algo novo para mim
e eu pensei mano eu não posso perder
esse dinheiro porque eu demorei três
meses para juntar r$ 120 Mas eu tive a
coragem e fiz nesse primeiro
investimento financeiro em 2016 eu saí
do cartório e conseguir um estágio
dentro do Banco Bradesco lá na Cidade de
Deus em Osasco ali o meu salário foi
para r$ 2500 então eu pensei pô eu já
sobreviverá com 680 com r$ 2500 então eu
corri não era o pensamento quinta que eu
tinha ali na época e aí A parte disso
toda aqueles pensamentos aqueles desejos
de comprar alguma coisa que antes eu não
podia ver eu à tona então eu consegui
ajudar dentro de casa pagar minha
faculdade o restante vou comprar uma de
roupas aiacos rolê até que então eu
gastava mais do que eu recebia e foi aí
que eu descobri o cartão de crédito eo
cheque especial e eu não tinha educação
financeira apropriada na época
Infelizmente eu acabei me dando chegando
numa dinda até de 20 mil reais e eu
lembro que essa dívida né me estressava
de tal maneira porque o devia a empresa
que eu trabalho não é isso para mim na
minha cabeça era uma loucura eu falei
mano tem que resolver essa situação e
como foi aí então que eu resolvi junto
com meu melhor amigo fazer renda extra a
gente criou um perfil no Instagram né
que o nome era MV outlet que era de
Murilo e Vinícius outlet vem criativo EA
partir disso a gente foi no centro de
São Paulo tirava a foto das roupas e
postaram no Instagram e aí a partir
disso a página começou a crescer muito
mas temos 20 mil seguidores e com isso
geramos uma renda extra E aí essa dívida
que eu tinha de 20 mil reais eu consegui
quitar em um ano
é usado que eu tive nessa época Cadinho
devidamente é que eu não poderia gastar
dinheiro que eu não tenho seja no cartão
de crédito seja no cheque especial e aí
a questão tô sempre priorizei também foi
sobre o aprendizado sobre o conhecimento
eu já tava lendo muitos livros ainda
dentro do ônibus dentro do metrô só que
eu falei por dentro do trabalho eu não
tô aprendendo mais nada né Já parece que
chegou no limite aqui de desenvolvimento
então foi aí que eu vi uma grande
oportunidade de migrar de trabalho que
foi para a p m g que é uma multinacional
de auditoria contábil eu prestei o
processo seletivo como ser jovem né
então foi bem arriscado eu tinha lhe
três meses para demonstrar a minha
performance dentro da empresa senão eu
iria ser demitido e o pior o salário era
de mil e quatrocentos reais 900reais
abaixo do que eu já recebi a no banco
irá trabalhar muito mais mas eu entendi
que lá dentro a minha questão
intelectual e assim desenvolver e
evoluir
o irmão símbolo dinheiro no curto prazo
focando no aprendizado porque o dinheiro
ia vir na frente como uma certa
consequência e foi justamente o que
aconteceu dentro da KPMG eu aprendi
muito sobre análise de empresas
relacionadas a bolsa de valores de
Capital fechado empresa no exterior como
olhar contabilidade E aí eu entendi como
que é o tipo de análise que eu poderia
fazer dentro dos meus investimentos e
até que eu pensei fale pouco já tem esse
conhecimento dentro de mim e eu entendo
te dentro da quebrada existem outras
pessoas que precisam desse conhecimento
só que eu não vou compartilhar isso de
uma maneira difícil de uma maneira
complicada daquela pessoa compreender
com o que eu aprendi dentro da empresa e
dentro dos livros e foi aí então que
surgiu a ideia de criar o favelado
investidor divisa hoje Compartilhar esse
conhecimento sobre educação financeira e
investimentos da maneira mais didática
possível sem o economês que a gente já
conhece por aí e sim com Fábio eles e
foi com isso e essa comunicação bem
didática e trocando idéias sempre com o
pessoal que o nosso projeto cresceu
muito e hoje a gente atinge milhares de
pessoas por mês e o que mais me emocione
e mais me deixa engajado com esse
propósito é justamente os feedbacks das
pessoas que nós recebemos durante esses
dois anos de favelado investidor ti por
exemplo tem aqui o caso do Thiago né que
é um ex-presidiário que cumpriu a sua
pena e quando ele tem vale a sua
liberdade ele mandou né De certa forma
para mim no Instagram falou por eu
estava pensando em voltar para o mundo
do crime só que eu acabei de ver uma
matéria sua aqui no jornal e eu entendo
que você veio da mesma realidade que eu
e eu vejo a possibilidade de mudar minha
vida e com isso ele começou a investir
começou cuidar na grana dele arrumou um
trabalho e hoje ele me mandar Direct até
hoje falando os um ex-presidiário e
favelado investidor então o objetivo
aqui do nosso projeto é justamente
transformar vai o lagos e favelados em
investidores e assim deixar que a
cobresal diminua na casa de cada um é
isso aí e Tamos juntos
E aí